mais je voudrais raconter une petite
histoire personnelle j'étais au Mexique
il y a deux semaines j'étais à Tulum une
ville du Mexique et je me balade et je
vois des pharmacies il y a beaucoup de
pharmacies et les panneaux de
médicaments sont sur le trottoir je
m'arrête et je dis qu'est-ce qui alors
je regarde
amoxicilline hivernactine
hydroxychloroquine azithromax
interdits c'est pratiquement ces poisons
je ne sais pas mais je vais dans la
pharmacie je dis dites-moi je peux
acheter ça me dit oui c'est c'est en
liberté il y a pas de problème pardon
par les Mexicains espagnols
espagnols quand même et je lui dis mais
il faut une ordonnance du médecin
n'oublie pas du tout absolument pas vous
allez venir alors est-ce peut-être que
le Mexique un pays ignorance ou
développé qui n'a pas compris que
c'était les poisons mais au-delà de ça
le problème il est pas là c'est très
bien ça c'est 20 ans et 30 ans on a
décidé qu'il était beaucoup plus facile
de faire ça en Chine parce que ça
coûtait moins cher ça c'est une histoire
de 30 40
je ne dis pas qu'on peut pas la changer
mais c'est toute l'histoire de la
désindustrialisation de la France et la
réindustrialisation qu'on essaie mais
qui va être très difficile il a raison
la tue monsieur verran c'est sur de fait
95% des matières premières
indispensables pour fabriquer les
médicaments pour le monde entier sont en
Chine en Inde au Pakistan en Asie donc
on est dans une situation de très grande
fragilité au regard des matières
premières et le deuxième aspect qui est
avéré c'est la désindustrialisation y
compris en matière pharmaceutique
d'autant plus que
en général ce sont des sites qu'on
appelle en France des sites
pétrochimiques ces vaisseaux si vous
voulez donc tout le monde veut qu'on
produisait médicament en France mais ou
en Europe mais c'est plutôt un peu plus
compliqué quand on dit qu'on implante
une usine chimique classée c'est des
eaux sur le territoire mais de fait
c'est un des objectifs prioritaires non
pas que français mais européen que
d'être capable de retrouver de la
souveraineté derrière de retrouver la
chaîne de fabrication de A à Z et le
plus dur ça restera les matières
premières dont la situation
quasimonopolistique et on a vu que c'est
dangereux quand on n'est pas capable de
produire soi-même des produits de santé
on l'avait vu avec les masques par
exemple ou avec avec d'autres
médicaments alors on a laissé aussi
tomber les masques inférieures beaucoup
pas dire et puis tout le reste les
nickel pour l'électricité etc enfin ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui mais moi je
voudrais revenir très intéressant ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces deux heures
parce que au fond et je voudrais dire à
Olivier Véran ministre que il est pas
c'est pas personnel ce que je vais dire
c'est que on donne avec le covid avec ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui l'Ukraine la
Russie les histoires d'électricité les
histoires de charges autant de quelque
chose et qui encore une fois ne commence
pas avec vous loin de là est-ce que la
politique doit être considérée comme
l'art de mieux mentir est-ce que le pays
du mensonge déconcertant explique c'est
pas la vérité si je mens c'est la vérité
quand je mens c'est à dire que au fond
sur un certain nombre de choses et je là
je vais parler du covid alors il y a on
ne pouvait pas savoir au départ ce que
ça pouvait être enfin franchement
monsieur Véran il s'est passé quand même
des choses pendant 3 ans tout à fait
hallucinante je m'explique par exemple
il y a il va y avoir trois ans que vous
avez pris le poste de Michel de la santé
car Agnès Buzin s'était présenté aux
élections municipales et vous dites je
vous cite le 18 février 2020 je n'ai pas
besoin de vérifier que la France soit
prête la France est prête et elle est
prête parce que nous avons un système de
santé extrêmement solide vous dites ça
en 2020 on sait très bien l'effondrement
de l'hôpital qui a commencé bien avant
évidemment vous qui a commencé qui a 20
ans le nombre de lit d'hôpital je
rappelle comme ça l'hospitalisation
complète a diminué de 100 000 pendant
que la population n'est plus de 65 ans
augmenté de 4 millions et puis vous
dites effectivement
un certain nombre de choses vous donnez
un certain déclarations mais
quand vous parlez du vaccin voilà on a
dit le vaccin effectivement l'histoire
des antivaxes et des provinces c'est pas
les antivax et les provinces c'est que
je peux comprendre qu'on s'est dit il
faut vacciner à supposer et je vais de
votre côté en disant voilà il faut
vacciner effectivement on va être et
c'est des gens Castex le Premier
ministre de l'époque votre premier
ministre qui disait à deux doses on est
vacciné et on est protégé et moi je me
rappelle avoir participé à des dizaines
de débats sur les chaînes de télévision
en continu ou vous aviez des médecins
encore une fois c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas personnaliser c'est pas Olivier
Véran le problème c'est un système qui
consiste à dire que il y avait aucun
problème or je rappelle quand même la
préhistoire de l'histoire Naya le
Ferguson faut le citer grand
modélisateur de l'Impérial College
London qui avait qui est responsable de
la disparition du boîtier du cheptel
britannique il modélisateur tu sais les
tableaux Excel et qu'est-ce qu'il dit il
dit va y avoir 50 millions de morts il
est allé voir Trump il était à voir
Macron il devait tout le monde ça va
être terrifiant vous allez avoir les
cercueils qui vont lire des les rues et
alors les gens se disent au principe de
précaution normal il attendait il se
retourne vers moderna fazer et compagnie
accélérer les vaccins accélérer les
autres disent attendez effectivement ce
que disait madame la période
d'expérimentation de Pfizer ici dans les
brochures c'est jusqu'à fin 2023 ça
c'est clair tout le monde peut lire ça
et Pfizer dit attendez moi je peux pas
on est encore en expérimentation en
vaccin expérimental et puis dire
attendez attendez on va pas attendre
qu'à cela ne tienne on va pas attendre
qu'il y a des millions de morts allez-y
et me disent c'est très important sur le
doigt pas ça on ne voit rien que disent
les labosses ok à tous les états pas la
France etc ils écoutaient on veut bien
mais une condition vous allez s'il y a
un problème d'effet indésirables ou des
faits secondaires on est responsable de
rien tu imagines que tu vas acheter ta
voiture tu as une rupture de frein tu
vas chez le fabricant et le fabricant
je termine là-dessus
pour tout le monde je suis invité pour
un face au Baba face aux Français et
vous avez vu que oui mais attends
français
[Musique]
vous voulez qu'on discute de ce que les
uns et les autres ont dit oui absolument
aucun problème absolument je crois que
c'est vous qui aviez commis un tweet
dans la fin de l'année 2021
c'est juste que vous savez j'ai beaucoup
travaillé moi-même je crois que vous
avez parlé de solution finale en lien
avec la vaccination vous pouvez nous
expliquer oui je peux m'écrire
absolument
des choses comme ça
alors moi je vous dis ce que vous avez
dit sur les vaccins et je vais vous
citer monsieur finale oui j'ai fait
annexer parce que j'étais tellement
indigné par la manière dont on traitait
non vaccinés quand votre Président je
vous parlais de ça a dit dans Le
Parisien votre président bien-aimé donc
vous êtes donc vous avez bien parlé de
la formation
exactement
j'ai envie il a pas dit genre merde il a
dit j'ai envie
ça me fait réagir j'ai entendu vous
regrettez vos propos pardon j'ai dit que
j'avais été excessif sur le mot de
solution finale mais je ne regrette sur
le mal de personnes sur le mode de
pensée de comparer la vaccination vous
pensez c'est une expression n'essayez
pas de prendre le petit détail sur
l'essentiel votre carrière votre
carrière contemporaine n'est pas faite
de détails elle est fait elle est faite
pardonnez-moi de prise de position
complotiste sans arrêt à revers de
l'histoire
attendez attendez attendez c'est à Lucie
explique vous avez la question non mais
vous avez parlé pendant deux heures vous
avez dit
vous êtes vraiment que vous le vouliez
ou non la question c'est qui parle moi
vous savez qui parle et vous savez vous
savez avec quelle conviction je viens
devant vous
avez salué je crois d'une manière assez
originale
vous me dit si je me trompe qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé vous lancez sur
plusieurs sujets pour qu'on voit qui
parle d'accord et vous voyez je vous
connais bien aussi figurez-vous je vous
livre de temps en temps et je
connaissais aussi votre passé avec
lequel j'avais pour lequel j'avais du
respect dans un passé lointain et
j'aimerais comprendre les mécanismes par
lesquels aujourd'hui vous en arrivez à
saluer l'attaque des bâtiments publics
officiels au Brésil après la victoire
démocratique de Lula par exemple
j'aimerais est-ce que ça à faire avec
l'autre sujet
réactionnaire tous les mensonges que
vous avez préféré pendant 3 jours j'ai
eu à freiner avec pendant 3 ans vous
avez menti en français vous avez menti
en français et vous avez alors vous
allez chercher quel est votre question
Olivier Véran moi j'ai pas de question
Olivier Béran je voulais dire simplement
Olivier
je veux dire comme
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire simplement
Olivier Véran que sa gestion du covid a
été une gestion tout à fait lamentable
et vous savez pourquoi et je reviens à
ce qui s'est passé avec les retraites du
coup on parle après il y a pourquoi il y
a une confiance
à tout ce que vous avez dit en fait la
question j'ai du respect pour le
restaurateur quand il m'engueule tout à
l'heure parce que j'imagine le
restaurateur qui a derrière qui passe 16
heures de jour et de nuit qui est en
galère qui était en panique etc je n'ai
je vous le dis monsieur Bercoff aucun
respect pour les la façon que vous avez
aujourd'hui et exercer le métier que
vous avez exercé hier d'une autre
manière
je vous en remercie